hello st. Louis I saw one of the most
astounding blunders yesterday I've ever
seen in elite top chess in my career I
have to put it in context however after
a very very hard tough complex six hour
long flight six hour long fight we had a
situation where young Ludwig hammer as
white was playing against tournament
leader veselin topalov is black black
has king and Bishop against King and
three pawns the own you cannot check
mate with King and Bishop alone you have
to hope that this pawn will one day make
it to a queen in this position young
just had a mental block he saw that if
he moved his King with the idea of
advancing his pawn and trading pawns he
makes a draw but he also saw that if he
moved his King here to e4 then king e6
and he would be losing he was also
afraid that if he moved his King to d4
there would be a check and once again he
would be losing he just had a temporary
blackout that he could have just simply
played the move f5 at once the pond
would be captured and then moved the
King to e5 and there is nothing that
black could do to prevent the loss of a
pawn so would the move f5 the game would
have been drawn everybody expected that
result amazingly again six hour long
game hammer came up with the move king
c6 and then after King e6 he realized
that it would do him no good to win the
bishop because by the time the White
King has won the bishop the black king
goes to f5 captures both pawns and this
pawn
rolls down the board for a touchdown and
with this gifted half point veselin
topalov took the lead and won his fourth
game out of 5 so an extraordinary turn
around just at the very end of the game
goes to show you how cruel chest can be
you work like a dog for six hours and
one bad move cost you the game an
amazing turnaround in round five
you